The town of Florencia de Benito Juarez was a typical little mountain town in Mexico, just 4,000 people. Quiet, until last Fall. Then a drug gang called the Zetas, affiliated with one of the big drug cartels, rolled into town. And people were pretty scared. The Zetas would stop people in the road and take their trucks. They walked the streets freely. The police were defenseless, or maybe they were just on the take, in the pockets of the gang.
佛罗伦西亚-德贝尼托华雷斯镇是墨西哥一个典型的小山镇，仅有4000人口。这里原本很安静，直到去年秋天。一个隶属于大型贩毒集团的贩毒帮派“洛斯哲塔斯”（Zetas）进入了镇子。人们感到非常恐惧。哲塔斯帮会在路上拦截行人，抢走他们的卡车。他们在街上自由地走动。警察束手无策，或者他们只是被收买了，站在了帮派那边。
I talked to a reporter who lives in the region, who asked as a precaution not to be named on the radio. The drug gangs are that powerful in the area. He's been talking to people in Florencia about this since the beginning, and he told me what happened. He said that in May, after months where people were terrified of these thugs, who'd more or less taken over, the Zetas went away for a few days. The reporter said this wasn't strange behavior for a Mexican drug gang. Everybody knew that they'd be back soon enough.
我采访了一位住在该地区的记者，出于安全考虑，他要求不要在电台点名。贩毒帮派在当地势力非常强大。从一开始，他就一直在和佛罗伦西亚的人们谈论此事，他告诉我发生了什么。他说，在五月份，经过几个月被这些已经几乎接管了城镇的暴徒折磨得担惊受怕的日子后，哲塔斯帮离开了几天。这位记者说，对于墨西哥贩毒帮派来说，这并不奇怪。大家都知道他们很快就会回来。
But while the Zetas were away, something really strange did happen. Another gang showed up, the Chapos, named, or nicknamed presumably, for Chapo Guzman, who runs one of the other big Mexican drug cartels.
但在哲塔斯帮离开期间，确实发生了一件非常奇怪的事情。另一个帮派出现了，自称是“查波帮”（Chapos），据推测是以“矮子”古兹曼（Chapo Guzman）的名字命名的，他经营着墨西哥另一个大型贩毒集团。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
For a while they thought they were from the same group. But the next day, the group of people went to go visit each of the different business establishments. They told them that they were from the Gulf Cartel, and that they were coming to liberate the town, so that they can live with peace and tranquility.
起初，他们以为他们是同一伙人。但第二天，这群人去拜访了每家不同的商业机构。他们告诉店主，他们来自海湾卡特尔（Gulf Cartel），他们来这里是为了解放城镇，让人们过上和平与安宁的生活。
In fact, the leader this new group, the Chapos, told store owners that if any gang member did something as petty as taking food from a store without paying, please come let him know. It would not be tolerated.
事实上，这个新团伙“查波帮”的头目告诉店主，如果有任何帮派成员做出从店里拿东西不给钱这样的小事，请务必告诉他。这种行为是绝对不能容忍的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"They were here to take out the garbage, meaning the Zetas," a woman from Florencia told this reporter. "They said they were good people. They weren't going to cause anybody in town any harm."
“他们来到这里是为了清除垃圾，也就是指哲塔斯帮，”佛罗伦西亚的一位女士告诉这位记者。“他们说他们是好人。他们不会伤害镇上的任何人。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
For the people of Florencia, they were protectors. The police fled town, as did the Mayor. And things were peaceful, with the Chapos in charge, for just a few days. And then, the Zetas returned. This was May 20 of this year, a Friday morning. Everybody expected and feared a big battle between the two.
对佛罗伦西亚的人民来说，他们是保护者。警察逃离了城镇，市长也走了。查波帮掌权后，这里平静了几天。然后，哲塔斯帮回来了。那是今年5月20日，一个周五的早晨。每个人都预感到并担心这两伙人之间会发生一场大战。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
What occurred then was that the Chapos warned the population that this was going to occur. And so the people stayed indoors, in their houses.
后来发生的事情是，查波帮警告了民众这件事将会发生。所以人们都待在室内，待在自己的房子里。
The fight started in town, and then continued in the mountains for a full day. And when it was over, authorities said that about a dozen were dead. The people in Florencia said it was a lot more, many dozens. The Chapos, the supposed protectors of Florencia, won the day. And as with anything heroic or sensational that happens in Mexico these days, of course, there are now corridos, folk ballads, about the battle. [SINGING] "Only 10 fallen men, reported the government, but I'm not stupid. I know what I'm saying. More than 60 idiots were left on the ground."
战斗在镇上开始，然后持续了一整天延伸到了山上。战斗结束后，当局称大约有十几人死亡。但佛罗伦西亚的人们说死亡人数远不止这些，有几十人之多。查波帮，也就是佛罗伦西亚所谓的保护者，赢得了胜利。就像如今墨西哥发生的任何英雄主义或耸人听闻的事情一样，当然，现在已经有了关于这场战斗的民间歌谣。 [演唱] “政府报告只有10人倒下，但我并不傻。我知道我在说什么。超过60个白痴被留在了地上。”
After that fight, people in town felt pretty safe.
那场战斗之后，镇上的人感到相当安全。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"The truth is, people feel protected," this woman's saying. "When the gang isn't around, that's when people are fearful." This reporter has seen a lot of what drug gangs do in small towns in Mexico, and he says he has never heard of this, a gang coming to town and people feeling safer.
“事实是，人们感到被保护，”这位女士说。“当帮派不在的时候，人们反而会感到恐惧。”这位记者在墨西哥的小城镇见识过许多贩毒帮派的所作所为，他说他从未听说过这种情况：一个帮派进入城镇，人们反而感觉更安全了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
It's surprising.
这令人惊讶。
Why is this one gang being so nice to this town?
为什么这个帮派对这个城镇如此友善？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
In truth, I don't really know what is occurring. I really don't know why. I know that they're fighting over territories.
事实上，我真的不知道发生了什么。我真的不知道为什么。我知道他们是在争夺地盘。
It's interesting to think that they would decide it would help them hold territory if they were simply nicer.
有趣的是，他们认为如果他们表现得更友善，会有助于他们控制地盘。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
It's a good strategy, no?
这策略不错，不是吗？
The strategy seems to be winning people over. On Father's Day, just a few weeks after the shoot-out, the Chapos hung a banner in town that read, "Happy Father's Day. We know that the family is the most important thing. CDG." CDG stands for Cartel de Gulfo, the Gulf Cartel.
这个策略似乎正在赢得民心。在父亲节那天，也就是枪战发生几周后，查波帮在镇上挂了一条横幅，上面写着：“父亲节快乐。我们知道家庭是最重要的。CDG。” CDG代表海湾卡特尔（Cartel de Gulfo）。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"I wasn't there, but my family told me about it," she's saying. "They told me that somebody went from street to street, handing out bottles of tequila to all the fathers, and wishing Happy Father's Day from the cartel, the Gulf Cartel."
“我当时不在场，但我的家人告诉了我这件事，”她说。“他们告诉我，有人挨家挨户地分发龙舌兰酒给所有的父亲，并代表卡特尔——海湾卡特尔，祝他们父亲节快乐。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
The reporter says to her, "So they're the promoters of the family?" And she says, "Yes." And then he jokes, "At this rate, they'll be dating the local girls soon." "That's already happening," she says.
记者问她：“所以他们成了家庭的推动者？”她说：“是的。”然后他开玩笑说：“照这个速度，他们很快就会和当地女孩约会了。”“这已经发生了，”她说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
"These aren't older guys," she says. "They're boys, at the most 20, 22 years old. Young guys at the age where a woman wants to fall in love. The girls, they see a cute guy in a truck, and their eyes meet."
“他们不是上了年纪的人，”她说。“他们是男孩，顶多20、22岁。正是女人想要坠入爱河的年纪。女孩们看到卡车里的可爱男孩，眼神就会对上。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
It's not all kittens and flowers, though. The Chapos have checkpoints at two entrances to the town, and keep a close eye on who can enter and exit. They issue orders. Like at the end of the school year, when people usually throw big parties, they told them not to, and everybody obeyed.
不过，事情并不全是美好的。查波帮在镇上的两个入口处设有检查站，密切关注谁可以进出。他们会发布命令。比如在学年结束时，人们通常会举办大型派对，他们告诉大家不要举办，每个人都照做了。
And just when the people of Florencia were feeling like things were fine, they were safe, this week, the mayor of the town, who apparently started cooperating with the Chapos, and the treasurer of the local ranchers association, both turned up dead, their bodies blindfolded and bound hand and foot, with a note, presumably from the Zetas, saying this will happen to everyone who supports and gives information to the Chapos.
就在佛罗伦西亚的人们觉得一切都好，他们很安全的时候，本周，据称开始与查波帮合作的镇长和当地牧场主协会的财务主管双双被发现死亡，尸体被蒙住双眼，手脚被捆绑，还附有一张显然来自哲塔斯帮的纸条，称这就是所有支持和向查波帮提供信息的人的下场。
But this reporter says that despite all that, as best as he can tell, people in town don't want the police and the traditional authorities to come back and run the place. They prefer the Chapos. The gangs are stronger than the authorities. They're better armed, better organized. And unlike the Mexican army, who sometimes breeze into town in a show of force for a couple days, the Chapos care enough to stick around.
但这位记者说，尽管如此，据他所知，镇上的人并不希望警察和传统当局回来管理这里。他们更喜欢查波帮。帮派比当局更强大。他们武装得更好，组织得更严密。而且不像墨西哥军队，有时只是为了示威而匆匆进镇待几天，查波帮关心到足以留在镇里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
There's so many towns, so many places. So then a town that's not on an important highway, that's in the mountains, kind of lost, there. Unfortunately, that's of little importance to many people.
有太多的城镇，太多的地方。所以一个不在重要公路线上、坐落在山上、有点被遗忘的城镇。不幸的是，这对许多人来说并不重要。
So for peace, and peace of mind, Florencia has the cartel. Thugs keeping order. And they keep out the Zetas better than the authorities ever did. It's a very romantic idea, that thugs aren't just killers, that they can be protectors, good guys. Lots of great movie characters are based on this very idea.
所以为了和平与安心，佛罗伦西亚有了卡特尔。用暴徒来维持秩序。而且他们比当局更好地把哲塔斯帮挡在了外面。这是一个非常浪漫的想法，暴徒不仅仅是杀手，他们也可以成为保护者、好人。许多伟大的电影角色都是基于这个想法塑造的。
Today on our show we have stories of people who look like thugs. They're accused of being thugs. Some of them act like thugs. But are they thugs? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show in two acts today. The first takes place in a city that, you could argue, for decades has been plagued by thugs. The second is about a woman who's stuck asking this very question I'm raising right here, is this guy a thug or not, about somebody who she's close to. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目里有关于那些看起来像暴徒的人的故事。他们被指控为暴徒。他们中的一些人表现得像暴徒。但他们真的是暴徒吗？来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕发生在一个可以说几十年来一直被暴徒困扰的城市。第二幕是关于一个女人，她正陷入我在这里提出的这个问题中：关于她亲近的人，这个家伙到底是暴徒还是什么？请留下来。
Act One. Thug me? No, Thug you.
第一幕。我是暴徒？不，你是暴徒。
Thug is an imprecise word, used to describe so many kinds of people. And it's subjective. One man's thug is another man's friendly neighborhood drug cartel. And the imprecision of the subjectivity of the word has been very apparent recently, during a massive world-changing drama, the revolution in Egypt that ousted president Hosni Mubarak, and during the months since then. Nancy Updike explains.
“暴徒”是一个不精确的词，被用来描述各种各样的人。而且它是主观的。一个人的暴徒是另一个人的友好社区贩毒卡特尔。而这个词的主观不精确性最近非常明显，在一场改变世界的巨大戏剧——推翻胡斯尼·穆巴拉克总统的埃及革命，以及之后的那几个月里。南希·厄普代克解释道。
The word thug has exploded in Egypt since the revolution. Street violence and crime are up. Muggings and break-ins and car theft. Who's to blame? Thugs. Churches have been attacked and burned, and deadly battles followed. Not just Christians versus Salafi Muslims. Also thugs, according to witnesses. Convicts have escaped in several jail and prison breaks, freeing up thugs. Rumors are constantly circulating that elements of the former regime are paying thugs to create mayhem and unravel the revolution. Thugs-- the word in Arabic is bultigiya-- can be anywhere. They are capable of anything, and everyone is against thugs.
自革命以来，“暴徒”这个词在埃及爆发了。街头暴力和犯罪都在增加。抢劫、入室盗窃和偷车。该怪谁？暴徒。教堂遭到袭击和焚烧，随后发生了致命的战斗。不仅仅是基督徒与萨拉菲派穆斯林之间的冲突。据目击者称，还有暴徒。囚犯在多次监狱越狱中逃脱，释放了暴徒。不断有传言称，前政权的残余势力正在花钱雇用暴徒制造混乱，以破坏革命。暴徒——这个词在阿拉伯语中是“bultigiya”——可能出现在任何地方。他们什么都干得出来，每个人都反对暴徒。
Which means that just about any person, if they're unlucky enough, can now be called a thug, and wind up in prison for it. I'll get to that in a minute. Because the word thug has a particular history in Egypt. For almost 30 years, during the dictatorship, "thugs" meant street criminals, yes, but it also meant men hired by the regime to intimidate and beat up citizens, alongside the police, or on their own.
这意味着几乎任何一个人，如果运气不好，现在都可能被称为暴徒，并因此入狱。我一会儿会讲到这一点。因为“暴徒”这个词在埃及有着特殊的历史。在近30年的独裁统治期间，“暴徒”意味着街头罪犯，没错，但它也意味着被政权雇佣来恐吓和殴打公民的人，他们和警察并肩作战，或者单独行动。
Some of them were trained employees of the state security forces. Others were freelance thugs, drawn from a pool of criminals, informants, men who needed money. Both groups, the trained men and the freelancers, wore ordinary clothes, no uniform. And they would show up at rallies, and protests, in voting stations, any place where citizens might need to be reminded that they could be beaten anytime.
其中一些是国家安全部队训练有素的雇员。其他人则是自由职业暴徒，来自罪犯、告密者和需要钱的人群。两组人，受过训练的和自由职业的，都穿着便装，没有制服。他们会出现在集会、抗议活动、投票站，任何可能需要提醒公民随时会被殴打的地方。
During the revolution, the regime sent thugs into Tahrir Square, on foot and on horseback, and on camel back. It was one of the craziest images of the entire uprising, these men galloping through the crowd and hitting people with sticks and whips as they rode. But that was the old Egypt. The new Egypt is being run by the government force that famously, crucially, did not attack the protesters on Tahrir Square, refused to shoot civilians, the military. The army is one of the few national institutions that many Egyptians trust. It's a conscript army. So lots of Egyptians have either served themselves or know a family member who's serving. A popular chant during the uprising was, "The army and the people are one," or "The army and the people or one hand." This is in contrast to the police, who killed over 800 people and injured thousands. They were the villains of the revolution. The army, for many Egyptians, was the revolution's protectors.
在革命期间，政权派暴徒进入解放广场，步行、骑马和骑骆驼。这是整个起义中最疯狂的画面之一，这些人冲进人群，在骑行时用棍棒和鞭子抽打人们。但这已经是旧埃及了。新埃及是由那个著名的、至关重要的、没有在解放广场攻击抗议者、拒绝向平民开火的政府力量——军队——所管理的。军队是许多埃及人信任的少数国家机构之一。这是一支征兵军队。所以许多埃及人要么自己服过役，要么认识正在服役的家庭成员。起义期间一个流行的口号是，“军队和人民是一体的”，或“军队和人民是一只手”。这与警察形成了鲜明的对比，警察杀害了800多人，打伤了数千人。他们是革命的恶棍。对许多埃及人来说，军队是革命的保护者。
One of the people who was on Tahrir Square during the revolution was the protagonist of this story, Ali Sobhi, a 28-year old actor I met in Cairo. Not a famous actor, just a working actor. While I was waiting to interview him, I watched him rehearse with a friend for a kid's performance, juggling these buckets back and forth in a small room in one of Cairo's grand old buildings.
革命期间在解放广场的人之一就是这个故事的主人公，阿里·索比，我在开罗认识的一位28岁的演员。不是名演员，只是个靠演戏谋生的演员。在我等待采访他时，我看着他和朋友排练一个儿童节目，在开罗一座宏伟古老建筑的一间小房间里，来回抛接这些水桶。
During the revolution, Ali was on Tahrir Square every day, except for two days, he said, when he went to check on his parents, because their neighborhood was being attacked by thugs. After the regime fell, Ali was one of the thousands of Egyptians walking the streets of Cairo giddy with freedom. One chant that took off during this period was, "Hold your head high, you're Egyptian." People would break into it spontaneously on the street, just this shout of pure joy and pride in the new Egypt. Ali says it was incredible how quickly people got used to not living in a police state, not being afraid.
革命期间，阿里每天都在解放广场，他说除了两天，他去查看他的父母，因为他们的社区正受到暴徒的袭击。政权垮台后，阿里是成千上万走在开罗街头、沉浸在自由喜悦中的埃及人之一。这段时期流传的一个口号是，“昂起头，你是埃及人。”人们会自发地在街上齐声高呼，这是一种对新埃及纯粹的喜悦和自豪。阿里说人们适应没有生活在警察国家、不再感到恐惧的速度之快，真是不可思议。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
Yes, I felt I had nothing to worry about. Even this whole idea of curfew. All over Egypt, no one felt that there was a curfew. The cafes were open. People were on the street. There are two chants that came out, like "What curfew? The Egyptians are here." "What is this curfew that you're speaking about," and actually both rhyme in Arabic. The entire country was alive.
是的，我觉得我没什么可担心的。甚至是整个宵禁的想法。在埃及各地，没人觉得有宵禁。咖啡馆开着。人们在街上。出现了两个口号，比如“什么宵禁？埃及人在这里。”“你在说什么宵禁”，实际上这两个在阿拉伯语里是押韵的。整个国家都活过来了。
Even in the midst of this euphoria after the dictatorship ended, Tahrir Square didn't fully empty out. Some people, including friends of Ali's, stayed, living in tents, cooking on butane stoves. Because to them, the revolution wasn't finished. The new Egypt was still being constructed. The country's hated emergency laws were still in effect. And they were going to keep up the pressure for reform.
即使在独裁统治结束后的这种兴奋中，解放广场也没有完全清空。一些人，包括阿里的朋友，留了下来，住在帐篷里，用丁烷炉做饭。因为对他们来说，革命还没有结束。新埃及还在建设中。该国令人憎恶的紧急状态法仍然有效。他们将继续施压要求改革。
Almost a month, to the day, after the old regime fell, on March 9, Ali was walking by Tahrir Square on his way to somewhere else, and he saw a wild scene. The army was there, and they were arresting people. And along with the army, there were also men in ordinary clothes with sticks, beating protesters. In the old Egypt, it would have been immediately clear what was going on. The men with sticks were thugs, working with the authorities. But Ali wasn't used to seeing thugs with the army. The army that had sided with the people, and refused to attack them during the revolution. He was used to seeing thugs with the police. This was new and disturbing.
旧政权垮台一个月后的那天，3月9日，阿里在去别处的路上经过解放广场，他看到了疯狂的一幕。军队在那里，他们在逮捕人。除了军队，还有穿着便装的人拿着棍棒殴打抗议者。在旧埃及，发生的事情会立刻变得清晰。拿着棍棒的人是与当局合作的暴徒。但阿里不习惯看到暴徒和军队在一起。那支在革命期间站在人民一边、拒绝攻击他们的军队。他习惯看到暴徒和警察在一起。这既新鲜又令人不安。
Ali is slight, maybe 5'7, 120 pounds. And he had long hair then, so he figured he would be spotted and arrested if he stayed. But he wanted to help his friends, so he pulled out his cell phone to let others know what was happening. He decided he was fine with being afraid and sticking around anyway.
阿里身材瘦小，大约5英尺7英寸（1.7米），120磅（54公斤）。他那时留着长发，所以他想如果他留下来，他会被发现并逮捕。但他想帮助他的朋友，所以他拿出手机让别人知道发生了什么。他决定即使感到害怕，无论如何都要留下来。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
The feeling was, I got rid of a president that had been in power for 30 years in 18 days, a prime minister that he appointed for us in seven days, or actually in five days. We could certainly overcome those thugs.
当时的感觉是，我在18天内除掉了一个执政30年的总统，在7天内，或者实际上在5天内，除掉了一个他为我们任命的总理。我们当然能战胜那些暴徒。
Ali wrote about what happened to him next in a 4,000 word Facebook post, a detailed inside account that stunned a lot of Egyptians when they read it. Ali's Facebook post is full of amazement at everything he saw the army do during the four days they held him. He's not afraid to be funny about something that is absolutely terrible. But mostly, he's just a careful observer. He gave us permission to have an actor read an English translation of what he wrote. In this excerpt, Ali's just been arrested by the army, along with almost 200 other people, and taken into the grounds of the Egyptian Museum, which the army had taken over and was using as an outpost in the area.
阿里在4000字的Facebook帖子中写下了他接下来遭遇的事情，这是一个详细的内部叙述，当埃及人读到它时，他们感到震惊。阿里的Facebook帖子充满了对他所见军队在他被关押的四天里所做一切的惊诧。他不怕对一些绝对可怕的事情表现得幽默。但大部分时间，他只是一个仔细的观察者。他允许我们让一位演员朗读他所写内容的英文译文。在这段节选里，阿里刚刚被军队逮捕，连同另外近200人，被带到了埃及博物馆的场地，军队已经接管了那里，并将其用作该地区的哨所。
First thing was a nice head-butt from a short soldier kid who couldn't reach my head. And I was telling him, "What's up, my cousin? Relax. What did I do?" By the way, I call all soldiers my cousin. So my cousin says, "You screwed up the country, you dirty sons of bitches." Another soldier was hitting me on the back of the neck, and I could see in the background an uneven battle between people hitting, and people getting hit.
第一件事是一个矮个子小兵用头撞了我一下，他都够不到我的头。我告诉他，“怎么了，我的表兄？放松。我做了什么？”顺便说一句，我管所有士兵叫“表兄”。所以我的表兄说，“你们搞砸了这个国家，你们这些肮脏的混蛋。”另一个士兵在打我的后颈，我可以看到背景里有几场不平衡的战斗，人们在殴打，人们在挨打。
Suddenly an officer, who looked like he'd had special forces training, super tough, was flying with his legs in the air like Bruce Lee right towards me. The soldier kids were holding me by the arms and pushing me forward for him, and he slammed me in the chest with those army issued boots. You know, the army that's with the people? The army that people used to see and chant "The people and the army are one"? I took the blow square in the chest, in precisely in the spot where I had my lung surgery two years ago.
突然，一个看起来受过特种部队训练、超级强壮的军官，像李小龙一样双脚腾空向我飞来。小兵们架着我的胳膊，把我往他那边推，他用那些军靴猛击我的胸口。你知道吗，那是与人民在一起的军队？是人们曾经看到并高呼“人民和军队是一体的”的那支军队？我正面挨了一脚，正中我两年前做肺部手术的地方。
I fell on the ground, and they dragged me by the hair. And they stood me up and tied me by the hair from a horizontal pole. And they kept hitting me in the knees and shins, and I would fall towards the ground and my hair would pull me back up. Then one soldier was holding a razor and hacking away at my hair. And an officer was doing his Kung Fu moves on me. And another soldier's hitting me with a wooden staff across my back, and another soldier's electrocuting me. My cousin says, "Lie down, you son of a bitch." He tied my hands behind my back and blindfolded me with this silly thing I could see everything through. And then he dragged me into a place he made me feel certain I would die in.
我倒在地上，他们拽着我的头发把我拖走。他们让我站起来，用头发把我绑在横杆上。他们不断地踢我的膝盖和胫骨，我就会倒向地面，头发会把我拽回去。然后一个士兵拿着剃刀割我的头发。一个军官对我使出他的功夫招式。另一个士兵用木棍抽我的背，另一个士兵在电击我。我的表兄说，“躺下，你这个混蛋。”他把我的手反绑在身后，用这个愚蠢的东西蒙住我的眼睛，透过它我什么都能看到。然后他把我拖到一个让我确信我会死掉的地方。
There were a lot of us there. We looked like piles of meat thrown on the ground. And soldiers were on top of us, raining down all kinds of beatings, electrocution, sticks, wooden staffs, electric cables, their boots.
那里有很多人。我们看起来像堆在地上的一堆肉。士兵们在我们身上，倾泻着各种殴打、电击、木棍、木棍、电缆、靴子。
And after a bit, they got this great idea, because we were refusing to die. So they thought instead they would kill the thing inside us, that if it were to die, we would die. All the soldiers together, military style, "Raise your head high, boy, you're Egyptian." Us, the people on the ground, all of us, "Wow, they laid off and finally got it. Thank you, God."
过了一会儿，他们想出了这个绝妙的主意，因为我们拒绝死。所以他们想，他们不如杀死我们体内的那种东西，如果它死了，我们也就死了。所有的士兵一起，军事风格地喊：“昂起头，伙计，你是埃及人。”我们，地上的那些人，我们所有人，“哇，他们终于放弃了，终于懂了。感谢上帝。”
And as we raised our heads up, because we're Egyptian, they kicked us in the head with their boots. Shock of a lifetime. This happened to everyone, which proved to me that it happened in a collective way, and that I'd really heard right when they all said together, "Raise your head high, boy, you're Egyptian," and then bang in your face. Long live Egypt.
当我们昂起头时，因为我们是埃及人，他们用靴子猛踢我们的头。一生的震撼。这发生在了每个人身上，这向我证明它是以集体方式发生的，而且当他们一起喊“昂起头，伙计，你是埃及人”，然后砰地一声踢在你的脸上时，我确实听对了。埃及万岁。
This was just the first of many beatings, and threats of worse beatings. Ali had been hassled, and arrested, and beaten up, by the police since he was a teenager. And he figured he would probably be roughed up this time, too. But he hadn't counted on systematic, sustained, brutality. Not from the army. Then he started to figure out that the beatings were just a preamble to being framed as a thug. The whole experience went from terrifying to bizarre. As an actor, Ali's been in movies. He's worked on location. And he knew what was happening, as he watched the soldiers setting the scene for the frame up.
这只是多次殴打和更严重殴打威胁的开始。阿里从十几岁起就一直被警察骚扰、逮捕和殴打。他以为这次他也会被打。但他没料到会有系统性、持续的残暴行为。不是来自军队。然后他开始意识到，这些殴打只是被栽赃为暴徒的前奏。整个经历从可怕变得离奇。作为一名演员，阿里演过电影。他在外景地工作过。当他看着士兵们为这场栽赃设置场景时，他知道发生了什么。
They started taking closeup shots of our faces, one by one. Three hand-held cameras, and one B2 camera, and a senior officer behind the B2 camera telling the soldiers with the other cameras what to do, like a movie director talking to a cinematographer. So they filmed us, and documented the state we were in. And we stood in rows, like in the army, and one by one we were searched, and then got on the bus. The bus drove us to the next scene in the movie, which was the military prosecution where the set was prepared, so that our arrests could be broadcast on television. An interior decoration officer was fixing up the set with two soldier assistants under him. There was a director of photography officer, with three or four light crew guys, and one cameraman, all soldiers.
他们开始一张一张地近距离拍摄我们的脸。三台手持摄像机，一台B2摄像机，B2摄像机后面的一名高级军官告诉拿着其他摄像机的士兵该做什么，就像电影导演对电影摄影师说话一样。所以他们拍摄了我们，记录了我们的状态。我们像在军队里一样站成几排，一个接一个地被搜身，然后上了公共汽车。公共汽车把我们载到了电影的下一场戏，那就是军事检察院，片场已经准备好了，以便我们的逮捕可以在电视上播出。一名室内装饰军官带着两名士兵助手在布置片场。有一名摄影导演军官，带着三四个灯光组成员，还有一名摄影师，都是士兵。
Anyway, they brought out the kids who looked dodgy, which included me because my front teeth are gone and my hair was a mess, and put us in the front. There was a soldier fixing the lighting. "The lighting is ready, sir." The director. "Get me their seized weapons." So the soldiers got knives and molotov cocktails, and what they said were bombs, which were the butane stoves we used to make tea, and laid them out on the table. And the interior decorator started adding his personal touch to the display, this next to that, this butane stove next to that knife.
总之，他们带出了看起来可疑的孩子，包括我，因为我的门牙掉了，头发乱糟糟的，把我们放在前面。有一个士兵在调整灯光。“灯光准备好了，长官。”导演。“把他们查获的武器给我拿来。”于是士兵们拿来了刀和莫洛托夫鸡尾酒（燃烧瓶），以及他们说是炸弹的东西，其实是我们用来煮茶的丁烷炉，把它们摆在桌子上。室内装饰师开始在他的展示中加入他的个人风格，这个放在那个旁边，这个丁烷炉放在那把刀旁边。
And this, I have to be fair, was indeed the fine touch of a master film industry decorator. Anyway. "All ready, sir." And the director of photography gave his order to the cameraman. And the man took his word, and started to take closeups, and medium shots, and wide angles, and everything any director's heart would desire.
而这一点，我必须公平地说，确实是一位电影行业大师级装饰师的精湛技艺。总之。“一切准备就绪，长官。”摄影导演向摄影师发出了指令。那人领会了意图，开始拍摄特写、中景、广角，以及任何导演心之所向的镜头。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
This is the news report where Ali appeared. The entire broadcast is on YouTube. You'll hear the announcer say bultigiya, thugs, right here.
这是阿里出现的新闻报道。整个广播都在YouTube上。你会听到播音员在这里说“bultigiya”，暴徒。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
And the scene is exactly as Ali described it. There are several rows of men, kneeling, with their hands behind their backs, in front of a long, low table with a table cloth, where weapons have been laid out, like a banquet. The camera shifts from panning shots, to wide angles, to closeups. And a spotlight is playing over the group. It's night time, so the spotlight is especially harsh. And about one minute in, the spotlight lands on Ali's face, right there in the front row. He thought they did a pretty good job of making him look like a thug.
场景正如阿里所描述的那样。有几排人，跪着，双手背在身后，前面是一张长长的低桌子，铺着桌布，武器像宴会一样摆在上面。摄像机从平移镜头切换到广角、切换到特写。聚光灯扫过这群人。天黑了，所以聚光灯特别刺眼。大约一分钟后，聚光灯落在阿里的脸上，就在第一排。他认为他们成功地让他看起来像个暴徒。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
I had broken teeth, and my hair was all over the place, and I had mud on my face. And the people next to me also. Their hair was cut with razors, and they were beaten in the face, so they had bloody face. In our culture, a thug has a scarred face. So yes we all looked like thugs, and when I saw the recording of the video that they had broadcast, yes, of course I looked like a thug. I did look like a thug.
我的牙齿断了，头发乱七八糟的，脸上还有泥。旁边的人也一样。他们的头发被剃刀割得乱七八糟，脸也被打肿了，所以脸上带着血。在我们的文化里，暴徒有疤痕脸。所以是的，我们看起来都像暴徒，当我看到他们播出的录像时，是的，我当然看起来像暴徒。我看起来确实像个暴徒。
The governing body that the military set up to run Egypt after the revolution is called the Supreme Council of the Armed Forces, SCAF, some Egyptians call it. One of the first things SCAF did was set up a Facebook page. This is a way they communicate with the country. And in one Facebook posting after another, SCAF has promised to protect the country from thugs and thuggery. They even added a new crime, called thuggery, to the penal code. And they made demonstrations illegal, if the demonstrations, quote, "harm national unity, societal peace, or public order." That's on top of the country's emergency laws.
军事委员会在革命后建立起来管理埃及的机构被称为武装部队最高委员会（SCAF）。SCAF做的第一件事就是建立了一个Facebook页面。这是他们与国家沟通的方式。在一条又一条的Facebook帖子中，SCAF承诺保护国家免受暴徒和暴行。他们甚至在刑法中增加了一项新的罪名，称为“暴行”。他们规定如果示威活动“损害国家团结、社会和平或公共秩序”，示威活动就是非法的。这还在国家的紧急状态法之上。
So, thugs are public enemy number one in these SCAF postings. And the opposite of thuggery and thugs? The noble youth of the revolution. That's a phrase that comes up a lot. It means people who helped topple the former regime. People like Ali.
所以，在这些SCAF的帖子里，暴徒是头号公敌。那暴行和暴徒的对立面是什么？革命的纯洁青年。这是一个经常出现的短语。它意味着推翻前政权的人。像阿里这样的人。
The military council, SCAF, wants stability. Egyptians want stability. They are tired of crime and uncertainty, and plenty of people are tired of the protests, too. I noticed that right before the report on Ali and the others' arrest-- this is the state TV newscast, by the way-- there was a story that combined the issues of thugs and stability, and seemed perfectly placed to tee up their report on Ali and the other supposed thugs the army had arrested. In the story, against the backdrop of the newly cleared Tahrir Square, people said they were glad to see some police were back. The news anchor said the police were there, quote, "to protect citizens, passers-by, and employees of governmental entities from troublemakers and outlaws."
阿里被控暴行等罪名。但他作为革命的活动家太出名了。四天后他被释放，并被宣判无罪。当时及以后几个月被捕的其他人在军事法庭受审，通常被控暴行，有时在20分钟的审判后被判处三、五年或七年徒刑。自二月以来有超过7000名平民被捕。
Ali was charged with thuggery, among other things. But he was too well known as an activist from the revolution. After four days he was freed, and he was acquitted of the charges. Other people arrested at that time, and in later months, were tried in military tribunals, often charged with thuggery, and sometimes getting a sentence of three or five or seven years, after a 20-minute trial. More than 7,000 civilians since February.
军事委员会SCAF否认军队在羁押期间虐待过任何人，尽管阿里描述的情况得到了许多人的证实。在几个月的压力之后，SCAF基本上承认，他们在3月9日逮捕阿里等人的行动，以及随后进行的速审，是严重的越权。这是从他们的Facebook页面上摘录的：“最高委员会负责人已下令重审，特别是那些在3月和4月事件中被捕的人，以便采取必要行动并立即释放所有革命的纯洁青年。”
The military council, SCAF, denies that the army has tortured anyone in custody, although what Ali described was corroborated by many others. And SCAF basically admitted, after months of pressure, that its arrest of Ali and others on March 9, and the quickie trials that followed, were a serious overreach. This is from their Facebook page. "The head of SCAF has ordered a retrial, especially those arrested in the events of the months of March and April, in order to take the necessary action and immediately release all the noble youth of the revolution."
军队在大多数埃及人中仍然非常受欢迎。但逮捕和冲突仍在继续，军事审判也一样。阿里从不美化军队。他不是革命期间高呼“军队和人民是一体的”那些人之一。但即使是一个现实主义者也会感到震惊。
The army is still very popular among the majority of Egyptians. But arrests and clashes keep happening, along with military trials. Ali never idealized the army. He wasn't one of the people chanting "The army and the people are one" during the revolution. But even a realist can be shocked.
[讲阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
他们命令我们说，“人民和军队是一只手”，不肯说的人就会被殴打。
They would order us to say, "The people and the army are one hand," and whoever wouldn't say it would be beaten up.
他们让你说这个作为玩笑？我不明白。
As a joke, they made you say it? I don't understand.
[讲阿拉伯语]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
他们在玩。他们在玩。他们在开怀大笑。他们在拿革命开玩笑。他们会说，“什么，你想除掉穆巴拉克。上帝保佑，我们会除掉你们所有人。”我说，“穆巴拉克走了。他离开了。”他们会说，“不，他没有。”
They were playing. They were playing. They were having a good laugh. They were making light of the revolution. They would say, "What, you want to get rid of Mubarak. We're going to get rid of all of you, God willing." And I'd say, "Mubarak's gone. He left." And they'd say, "No, he didn't."
解放广场上又有了新的抗议活动。就在上周，据埃及报纸《Almasry Alyoum》报道，一个军事委员会表示，解放广场的静坐示威应该结束，因为广场上有暴徒，他们可能会损害革命的事业。这可能是真的。但现在谁还会信任军方，来决定谁是暴徒，谁是纯洁青年呢？
There are new protests on Tahrir Square. And just last week, according to the Egyptian newspaper, Almasry Alyoum , a military committee said that the sit-in on Tahrir Square should end, because there are thugs on the square, who could harm the cause of the revolution. It could be true. But who's going to trust the military now, to decide who's a thug, and who's a noble youth?
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。阿里的Facebook帖子由莫塔兹·阿塔拉和威姆·埃尔-塔米米翻译成英文。朗读译文的演员是迈克尔·切努斯。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Ali's Facebook posting was translated into English by Moataz Atallah and Wiam el-Tamimi. The actor reading the translation was Michael Chernus.
接下来，拥抱，而不是暴徒。一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
Coming up, Hugs, not Thugs. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，暴徒，他们的多种形式，以及多种形式的暴行。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，终身监禁者。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, thugs, the many forms of them, and the many forms of thuggery. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Lifers.
这是一个名叫肯尼斯·威廉姆斯的孩子的成长故事，也是一个名叫托尼娅·威廉姆斯的成年人的故事。为了不让你搞混，托尼娅和肯尼斯有相同的姓氏，但他们没有亲属关系。在肯尼斯的大部分生活里，托尼娅对肯尼斯，以及他的“暴徒行为”都有着各种各样的想法，而肯尼斯可能分享过，也可能没有。记者劳拉·贝尔采访了托尼娅。
This is a story of a kid, named Kenneth Williams, and it's the story of an adult, named Ton'Nea Williams. And just so you don't get tripped up here, Ton'nea and Kenneth have the same last name, but they are not related. And for most of Kenneth's life, Ton'Nea has had all kinds of ideas about Kenneth, and his thuggishness, that Kenneth may or may not have shared. Reporter Laura Beil spoke to Ton'Nea about this.
托尼娅·威廉姆斯和我是在同一所小学当妈妈。直到最近，除了基本情况外，我对她了解不多。我知道她是高中助理校长。她是负责纪律的人，她看起来也确实像干这一行的。她镇定自若，令人敬畏，一丝不苟，而且很漂亮。
Ton'Nea Williams and I are moms at the same elementary school. Until recently, I didn't know much about her, beyond the basics. I knew she was an assistant principal at the high school. She's the one in charge of discipline, and she looks the part. She's poised, commanding, meticulously put together, and beautiful.
我们去年十二月在一次学校合唱团出国旅行中建立了友谊。在一次漫长的公共汽车旅程中，我了解到她是怎样投身教育事业的，以及她是如何被她试图指导的一个孩子之间的关系深深影响的。她1992年刚从大学毕业就开始了工作。“我要去拯救世界，”她说。她在亚历山大青年服务中心找到了一份工作，那是阿肯色州小石城外的一所少年拘留所。
We forged a friendship last December, during a trip abroad with the school choir. On one long bus ride, I learned about how she got into education, and about how she'd been affected, deeply affected, by her relationship with one of the kids she had tried to mentor. She started in 1992 when she was fresh out of college. "I was going to save the world," she said. She took a job at the Alexander Youth Services Center, the juvenile detention facility outside of Little Rock, Arkansas.
她刚工作的第一天就被指派对一个叫肯尼斯的孩子进行入职面试。他从监狱里逃了出来，刚在几英里外的阿肯色州中部森林里被抓获。他将成为她的第一个任务。她不确定会遇到什么。
She had been on the job exactly one day when she was assigned an intake interview on a kid named Kenneth. He had escaped from prison and had just been recaptured a couple of miles away in the woods of central Arkansas. He was to be her first assignment. She wasn't sure what to expect.
我记得看着这个身高4英尺11英寸（约1.5米）、体重不超过98磅（约44公斤）的孩子，头发里夹着树枝，胳膊上因为跑过树林而带着抓痕。我心想，一个孩子怎么会在11或12岁时就来到这种地方？你该怎么办？他做了什么？直到我完成入职面试，我才意识到他最初是因为什么被送到青年服务中心的。他在派恩布拉夫的一家经销商处偷车。
I remember looking at this four foot eleven kid that weighed no more than 98 pounds, with twigs in his hair, and scratches on his arm from running through the woods. And I thought to myself, how does a kid get into this place at 11 or 12? What do you do? What did he do? And it wasn't until I finished the intake interview that I realized what he was sent to Youth Services for in the beginning. He was stealing vehicles from a dealership in Pine Bluff.
他在偷窃，但他太年轻了，与其说是个罪犯，不如说是个孩子，即使是在她审问他的时候。
He was stealing, but he was so young, more boy than criminal, even as she was questioning him.
他是个有礼貌的孩子。我甚至没想到他会，你知道，好相处。他在一家青少年教养所里。他总是说“是的，女士”，“不，女士”。我向培训我的女士表达了我的想法，“天哪。”她基本告诉不要把心放得太开，因为你会失望的。但我没那么看。我说，“好吧，如果你给孩子们足够的爱，如果你在他们这么小的时候给他们提供机会，他们就不会来这里。”但她告诉我，“守护好你的心，习惯它。”
He's this polite kid. I'm not even expecting him to be, you know, nice. He's in a correctional facility for youth. And he's yes, ma'am and he's no, ma'am. And I expressed to the lady that was training me, "Oh, my God." She basically told me not to open my heart too wide, because I would be let down. But I just didn't see that. I said, "Well, if you love on kids enough, if you provide them with opportunity at this young age, they won't come here." But she told me, "Guard your heart and get used to it."
她没有守护好她的心。那看起来不太对劲。相反，托尼娅对自己许下了一个承诺。她会找到一种与肯尼斯建立联系的方法，并让他走上一条更好的道路。重要的是要理解，托尼娅不仅仅是一个想一个接一个改变世界的幼稚的22岁年轻人。她自己也经历过艰难。
She didn't guard her heart. It just didn't seem right. Instead, Ton'Nea made a promise to herself. She would find a way to connect with Kenneth, and set him on a better path. It's important to understand that Ton'Nea was not just a naive 22-year old who wanted to change the world one kid at the time. She'd had a hard time coming up herself.
托尼娅九岁时，她母亲把她和她的五个兄弟姐妹送进了寄养家庭。所有六个孩子都待在由国家经营的家里，直到后来被家庭一个接一个地领养。托尼娅和她妹妹是最后两个被安置的。在一年多没有父母、漂泊无依后，她父亲出现并认领了她。她记得自己当时想，如果我能让某人爱我、关心我，我就会好起来的。
When Ton'Nea was nine, her mother sent her and her five brothers and sisters to live in foster care. All six stayed in a state-run home until families took them in, one by one. Ton'Nea and her sister were the last two to be placed. After more than a year, parentless and adrift, her father showed up and claimed her. She remembers thinking, if only I could get someone to love me and care about me, I'll be OK.
在她的例子里，她是对的。她能熬过那些年是因为她遇到的导师，大多数是通过学校，他们看到了她的潜力并不断鼓励她。所以当托尼娅遇见肯尼斯时，她以自己的生活作为蓝图。她全天候地劝说他留在学校和设定长期目标的重要性。她付钱给肯尼斯，让他帮她带孩子，教他责任感。托尼娅也让她丈夫参与进来，作为男性的榜样，因为肯尼斯的父亲早就离开了。她帮助肯尼斯的母亲找到了更好的工作，并把他的家人搬到了一个更安全的社区，就在她自己家附近。通过她所有的努力，她可以看到他变得更有责任感。
And in her case, she was right. She survived those years because of mentors she met, mostly through school, who saw her potential and kept encouraging her. So when Ton'Nea met Kenneth, she looked to her own life as a blueprint for what to do. She counseled him around the clock about the importance of staying in school and setting long term goals. She paid Kenneth to babysit her children, to teach him responsibility. Ton'Nea got her husband involved, too, as a male role model, since Kenneth's dad was long gone. She helped Kenneth's mom get a better job and moved his family to a safer neighborhood, right around the corner from her own. And for all of her efforts, she could see him becoming more accountable.
他在上学。他遵守宵禁。说他上学听起来很简单，这并不是什么了不起的成就。但考虑到他的过去，这是巨大的。他会志愿奉献时间，并且会去教堂，这也是巨大的。一天早上他出现了，没有事先通知。“我想和你一起去教堂。”所以像这样的迹象，让我觉得有进展。
He was going to school. He was meeting curfew. It sounds simple to say he went to school, and it's not a big accomplishment. But considering what I was working with, in terms of his past, that was huge. It was also huge that he would volunteer his time, and that he would go to church. One morning he shows up, no prior notice. "I'd like to go to church with you." So it was signs like that, that I felt there was progress being made.
我觉得我们在正确的轨道上。这种感觉真好。那些悲观者说，“一旦孩子们陷入青少年教养系统，他们就永远不会改变。”我想说，“看到了吗？这是可以做到的。这是可以做到的。我们可以改变这些孩子。看，这是一个例子。”他要成为我改变的代言人。
I felt like we were on the right track. It was a really good feeling. And the naysayers that said, "Once the kids get caught up in the juvenile correctional system, they never change." I wanted to say, "See? It can be done. It can be done. We can change these kids. See, here's an example." He was to be my poster child for change.
他就像家人一样。他会不时顺道打个招呼，或者在周末烧烤时抓个汉堡吃。拘留中心孩子们的情况，尤其是肯尼斯，进展得太好了，以至于她决定超越作为政府社会工作者的朝九晚五的工作，成为一名活动家。她和丈夫在小石城外创办了青年篮球营。
He was like family. He would drop in from time to time to say hello, or grab a burger at a weekend barbecue. Things with kids at the detention center, and especially with Kenneth, were going so well that she decided to move beyond her nine-to-five job as a government caseworker, and become an activist. She and her husband started youth basketball camps outside Little Rock.
1997年，托尼娅利用她是一个高个美女的事实，参加并赢得了阿肯色州美国夫人称号。当然，参加选美比赛需要一个事业，她的是青少年犯罪预防。她的口号？通过教育和课外活动帮助所有青年看到他们的潜力。不朗朗上口，但很真诚。她会在全州各地的教堂和青年团体进行演讲，讲述留在学校和远离麻烦的重要性。
In 1997, Ton'nea capitalized on the fact that she is a towering beauty to run for and win the title of Mrs. Arkansas America. You need a cause to be in a pageant, of course, and hers was juvenile crime prevention. Her slogan? Helping all youth see their potential through education and extracurricular activities. Not catchy, but sincere. She'd give speeches to churches and youth groups throughout the state about the importance of staying in school and keeping out of trouble.
但第二年，事情变了。在她居住的派恩布拉夫，两名阿肯色大学的学生在一家当地餐馆外被持枪抢劫、绑架，并被枪杀在附近的田野里。那个女孩，大学里的拉拉队长，去世了。但另一名学生幸存了下来，神志清醒到足以爬到路上招手求救。经过三天的搜捕，警方找到了嫌疑人。
But the next year, things changed. In Pine Bluff, where she lived, two University of Arkansas students were robbed at gunpoint outside a local restaurant, kidnapped, and shot in a nearby field. The girl, a cheerleader at the university, died. But the other student survived, remaining conscious enough to crawl to a road and flag down help. After a three-day manhunt, the police found their suspect.
今天下午，杰斐逊县治安官的副手逮捕了19岁的肯尼斯·威廉姆斯。他现在被指控犯有一级谋杀和企图一级谋杀罪。
This afternoon, Jefferson County Sheriff's deputies arrested 19 year old Kenneth Williams. He is now charged with capital murder and attempted capital murder.
我在电视上听到了，我坐在那里。就像，风被从我身体里吸走了。我拿起电话，打给我的一位朋友，问他们是否听说过他被捕的事？他们告诉我是的。我只是拿着电话，我能听到他们在说你好，你好。我只是坐在那里。
I heard it on television, and I sat. It's like, the wind was knocked out of me. And I got on the phone, and I called a friend of mine, and I asked them had they heard anything about him being arrested? And they told me yes. And I just held the phone, and I could hear them saying hello, hello. And I was just sitting there.
你在想什么？你在想什么？
And what did you think? What were you thinking?
你搞错了。这不可能。这不可能。在肯尼斯被逮捕之前，作为嫌疑人，我记得听说过一颗金牙。这个人有一颗金牙。他没有。
You've made a mistake. This is not possible. It's not possible. Prior to Kenneth being arrested, as a suspect, I remember hearing about a gold tooth. This person had a gold tooth. He doesn't have one.
肯尼斯的表兄确实有一颗金牙，托尼娅看到的警方素描看起来就像这个表兄。她确信警方抓错了人。托尼娅说她周围的每个人——朋友、同事——都和肯尼斯划清了界限。当肯尼斯的辩护律师请托尼娅为他出庭作证时，连她的丈夫肖恩都试图劝她不要这样做。但她还是站上了证人席。
Kenneth had a cousin who did have a gold tooth, and the police sketches Ton'Nea had seen looked just like this cousin. She was sure police had gotten the wrong guy. Ton'Nea says everyone around her-- friends, coworkers-- washed their hands of Kenneth. When Kenneth's defense attorneys asked Ton'Nea to be a character witness on his behalf, even her husband, Shawn, tried to talk her out of it. She took the stand anyway.
我记得最清楚的是和他们分享，这不是我认识的那个人。我不认识会反复枪杀一名女性并杀死她的人。我也不认识会把另一个人置于死地的人。我不认识那样的人。
What I remember most is sharing with them, this is not the person that I know. I don't know someone that would repeatedly shoot a female and kill her. And I don't know anyone that would leave another person for dead. I don't know anyone like that.
肯尼斯——告诉我他的反应。
And was Kenneth-- tell me his reaction.
我记得他坐在和律师一起的桌子旁。在我作证后，他看向我坐着的法庭区域，他对我笑了。我把他的笑看作——我看到了里面的痛苦。我看到一个笑容，但我看到了里面的痛苦，他正在经历这个过程，他被指控为一些无辜的事情，现在他将余生都在监狱里度过。但那是感激。谢谢。谢谢你关心到足以来到这里。谢谢你关心到足以分享我是什么样的人。
I remember him sitting at the table with his attorneys. And after I testified, he looked over at the area of the courtroom that I was sitting in, and he smiled at me. I took his smile as-- I saw pain in it. I saw a smile but I saw a pain in it, that he was going through this process, that he was innocent of something that he would now spend the rest of his life in prison for. But it was of gratitude. Thank you. Thank you for caring enough to be here. Thank you for caring enough to share the person that I am.
陪审团并没有那么同情。肯尼斯被判定犯有一级谋杀罪、企图一级谋杀罪，以及其他七项罪名，包括绑架、加重抢劫和盗窃。他被判终身监禁且不得假释。尽管如此，检察官告诉托尼娅，因为她，肯尼斯可能免于死刑。
The jury was not so sympathetic. Kenneth was convicted of capital murder, attempted capital murder, and seven other counts, including kidnapping, aggravated robbery, and theft. He was sentenced to life without parole. Still, prosecutors told Ton'Nea that because of her, Kenneth had probably been spared the death penalty.
即使肯尼斯坐牢了，托尼娅也无法放手。她成年后的大部分时间都在关注肯尼斯，试图让他远离监狱。现在，他却偏偏在那里。
Even as Kenneth sat behind bars, Ton'Nea couldn't let him go. She had spent most of her adult life with one eye on Kenneth, trying to keep him out of prison. And now, that's exactly where he was.
肯尼斯时不时会打电话。托尼娅试图让他保持精神振奋。她告诉他要对上帝和真相保持信心。那时她的生活在改变。她辞去了第一次见到肯尼斯的那家少年拘留中心的工作，成为了一名教师。她不想试图拯救那些已经惹上法律麻烦的孩子，而是想让他们彻底远离监狱。她全心投入到她的新工作中。她专注于抚养她的家庭。她试图不被肯尼斯占据心神。
Kenneth called every so often. Ton'Nea tried to keep his spirits up. She told him to put his faith in God and in the truth. Her life was changing by then. She'd quit her job at the juvenile detention center where she'd first met Kenneth, and became a teacher. Instead of trying to rescue kids who were already in trouble with the law, she wanted to keep them out of jail altogether. She threw herself into her new job. She focused on raising her family. And she tried not to be preoccupied with Kenneth.
一天晚上，我看到了来电显示，我知道这是肯尼斯打来的电话，我没有接。我第二天早上照常起床。我在拐角的便利店停了一下，我记得店员告诉我她从扫描仪里听到了我的地址，或者我的街道，有人从监狱里逃了出来。我被吓了一跳，但我继续去上班了。州警来到我的工作单位，分享了发生了什么。肯尼斯逃跑了，他们正在找他。
One night, I saw the caller ID, and I knew that it was a call coming through from Kenneth, and I did not answer. I got up the next morning, as usual. I stopped by the corner convenience store, and I remember the clerk telling me that she heard my address, or my street, over the scanner, that someone had escaped from prison. I was taken back by it, but I continued on to work. And the state trooper came to my job and shared what had happened. Kenneth had escaped, and they were looking for him.
我为他感到害怕。州警用的是真枪。他的心态可能是，我不会再回监狱了。你必须杀了我。
I was scared for him. State troopers use real guns. And he may have the mindset of, I will not go back to prison. You're going to have to kill me.
新闻报道宣布了关于搜捕的全天候更新。但故事也问道，一个囚犯怎么可能在一个月不到后就从戒备森严的监狱里逃出来？
News reports announced round-the-clock updates on the manhunt. But also, stories asked, how on earth does an inmate escape a maximum security prison after being there less than a month?
监狱说它每天进行五次强制点名，但昨天那两次点名之间，威廉姆斯神秘地消失了。
The prison says it conducts five mandatory head counts each day, but somewhere in between two of those counts yesterday, Williams mysteriously disappeared.
发生了什么。他设法爬上了一辆泔水车，滑进了一桶泔水里。
Here's what happened. He was able to get on a slop truck, and slip into a bucket of slop.
一桶泔水。
A bucket of slop.
这就像猪食，你喂猪的东西。他设法在一桶泔水里活了下来，足够逃跑。
It just is like hog slop, what you feed the hogs. And he was able to survive in a bucket of slop long enough to escape.
肯尼斯被捕了，但造成了伤亡。在逃跑过程中，他在监狱附近偷了一辆卡车。他用那个人的枪向卡车主人开了七枪才逃走，杀死了他。一天后，在密苏里州试图甩掉警察时，肯尼斯正面撞上了一辆运货卡车，司机在撞车事故中死亡。肯尼斯被抓获并被判处死刑。
Kenneth was captured, but not without casualties. In making his escape, he stole a truck near the prison. He shot the owner of the truck, with the man's own gun, seven times before fleeing, killing him. A day later, trying to outrun police in Missouri, Kenneth slammed head-on into a delivery truck, and the driver died in the crash. Kenneth was caught and sentenced to death row.
托尼娅不禁感到对在肯尼斯逃跑过程中死去的人负责。为什么那天晚上她不接电话？对他来说，这真的是一次求助。也许她能劝他放弃绝望。
Ton'Nea couldn't help feeling responsible for the people who died during Kenneth's escape. Why didn't she just pick up the phone that night? To her it was, quite literally, a call for help. Maybe she could have talked him down from his desperation.
所以越狱、谋杀，以及发生的一切，这让你对他的清白产生了怀疑吗？
So the prison break, and the murder, and everything that happened, did that raise doubts for you about his innocence?
当我听到谋杀案时，我立刻想，好吧，他可能是为了逃跑而试图偷窃或抢劫。我从未想过他恶意地去那个地点杀人。我觉得，你有一个被关押的人，他们刚刚做了一次绝望的尝试，因为他们是清白的。
When I heard about the murder, I immediately thought, well he probably was trying to steal or rob to get away. I never thought that he maliciously went to the location to kill this person. I felt like, you have a person incarcerated, and they've just made a desperate attempt, because they are innocent.
这让我感到惊讶。尽管她知道肯尼斯枪杀了卡车车主，她仍然确信他是无辜的？
This surprised me. Even though she knew Kenneth shot the truck owner, she was still certain he was innocent?
几年过去了。托尼娅几乎每天都想到肯尼斯。然后在2005年，发生了两件事改变了托尼娅的生活。
Years went by. Ton'Nea thought about Kenneth almost every day. Then in 2005, two things happened that changed Ton'Nea's life.
托尼娅的一个姐姐失去了她四个儿子的监护权，他们都不到10岁。她无法忍受看到更多的年幼男孩被送进寄养家庭，特别是在失去肯尼斯之后。已经有了三个自己的孩子，她和丈夫收养了她的四个侄子，突然让她家里有了七个孩子。
One of Ton'Nea's sisters lost custody of her four sons, all of them under 10. She could not bear the idea of seeing more young boys surrendered to foster care, especially after losing Kenneth. Already with three of their own, she and her husband adopted her four nephews, suddenly giving her a household of seven children.
还发生了一件事。那年夏天，派恩布拉夫的当地报纸《派恩布拉夫商业报》发表了一篇文章，宣布肯尼斯对最初的犯罪招供。他在写给报纸的一封六页的信中说，他找到了上帝，需要为他所做的事情赎罪。他还承认了另一宗他从未被怀疑犯下的谋杀案。那颗金牙，托尼娅这么多年来一直紧抓不放的东西，只是他可以戴上和取下的牙套。
One more thing happened. That summer, Pine Bluff's local newspaper, The Pine Bluff Commercial , published an article announcing Kenneth's confession to the original crime. He'd found God, he said, in a six-page letter to the paper, and needed to atone for what he'd done. He also admitted to another murder that he was never even suspected of committing. The gold tooth, the thing Ton'Nea had clung to all these years, was just a cap that he could put on and take off.
我的一个朋友从派恩布拉夫打电话给我，实际上把文章的大部分都读给我听了。我说，“我需要一份复印件。我需要一份。我需要自己读一遍。不，不，不。我需要自己读。我的天啊。我的天啊。这么久以来。”
A friend of mine called me, from Pine Bluff, and actually read most of the article to me. And I said, "I need a copy. I need a copy. I need to read it for myself. No, no, no. I need to read it for myself. Oh my God. Oh my God. All this time."
几天来，她一遍又一遍地读这个故事，然后回顾她所有的步骤，试图找出她哪里做错了。
For days she would read the story again and again, then retrace all of her steps, trying to pinpoint where she'd gone wrong.
你知道，我不哭。我很生气，因为我在想，伙计，我支持你，相信你，对你有信心，认为你是清白的。我真的相信你不是犯下这些罪行的人。我觉得自己很愚蠢。我不认为眼泪是其中的一部分。我，就像，真的很愤怒。我很愤怒，我作证了，而你实际上杀死了这个女孩。
You know, I don't cry. I'm mad, because I'm thinking, dude, I stood by you, and believed, and had faith in you that you were innocent. And I really believed that you were not the one that committed these crimes. I felt foolish. I don't think tears were a part of that. I'm, like, really pissed off. I'm pissed off that I testified, and you actually killed this girl.
坦白迫使托尼娅面对关于肯尼斯的一些令人不安的事实。很明显，她从来没有真正了解他是谁，或者他需要什么。她只是看不出来。如果是这样的话，那对于她每天在工作中一起工作的孩子们意味着什么？那对于她自己在家里的孩子意味着什么？如果她也对他们弄错了呢？所以当我就肯尼斯的遗憾问她时，她并没有放弃他。多年后的今天，她还在解决问题。
The confession forced Ton'Nea to face some disturbing truths about Kenneth. Clearly she never really knew who he was, or what he needed. She just couldn't see it. And if that was the case, what did that mean for the kids she works with every day at her job? What did it mean for her own kids at home? What if she was getting it wrong with them, too? So when I ask her about regrets over Kenneth, she doesn't write him off. All these years later, she's still problem solving.
我不相信我做了我能做的一切。我仍然希望有什么我能做的事情来改变他一生的整个轨迹。即使是现在。显然，他需要一些不同的东西。关于肯尼斯还能做些什么呢？我想问他那个问题。而且我想让那个问题成为面对面的问题。你还需要什么？还能做些什么来防止这些事件发生？
I'm not convinced I did everything that I could have. I still wish there was something that I could have done to change the whole trajectory of his life. Even now. Obviously, he needed something different. What else could have been done with Kenneth? I would like to ask him that question. And I would like for that question to be a face-to-face question. What else did you need? What else could have been done to prevent these events from happening?
所以我要跟着标志往——
So I'm going to follow the signs for--
西。
West.
哦，那是派恩布拉夫。
Oh, there's Pine Bluff.
那是今年五月一个下雨、冷得离谱的日子，当托尼娅、我的制作人罗宾和我从机场驱车从小石城前往派恩布拉夫南部的瓦纳超级监狱，去问他这些问题时。我们迟到了。这让人有点紧张。一种奇怪的紧张，对于两个永远不会再见到对方的人之间的重逢来说，迟到了。当我们沿65号高速公路向南行驶时，罗宾与托尼娅确认。
It's a rainy, freakishly cold day this May, when Ton'Nea, my producer, Robyn, and I, drive from the airport in Little Rock to the Varner Supermax Unit south of Pine Bluff, to ask him those questions. We're running late. Its a little nerve-wracking. A weird kind of nerve-wracking, being late for a reunion between two people who will never see each other again. As we drive south on Highway 65, Robyn checks in with Ton'Nea.
托尼娅，我想在到达那里之前问你，我们应该待尽可能长的时间吗？
Ton'Nea, I wanted to ask you before we get there, should we stay as long as we can?
我有点紧张。我不知道。如果那是一件我们可以边走边衡量的事情呢？你知道，你以为你知道，在进入一种情况时，你将如何反应，以及你将感受到的情绪。但在现实中，直到你到达那里，你真的不知道。而且因为我保留了其中的很多东西一段时间，我真的不知道那对我来说会是什么样子。
I'm kind of nervous. I don't know. If that's something that we can kind of gauge as we go? You know, you think you know, going into a situation, how you're going to respond, and the emotions that you will feel. But in actuality, until you get there, you really don't know. And because I've held onto a lot of this for awhile, I really don't know what that's going to look like for me.
我们待了整个探视时间，两个小时。但监狱官员不让我们记录这次访问。发生了什么事。
We stay for the whole visitation time, two hours. But the prison officials won't let us record the visit. Here's what happens.
我们在一个空荡荡的、乏味的、低天花板的房间里见到他，墙边有一排从墙上突出出来的玻璃间。要透过玻璃交谈，你必须大声喊叫。我们是这天唯一的访客，肯尼斯独自等待。托尼娅先走到了他身边，哭了。她很难喘过气来。
We meet him in a bare, drab, low ceiling room, with a lineup of glass booths that jut out from one of the walls. To have a conversation through the glass, you have to practically shout. We are the only visitors this day, and Kenneth waits alone. Ton'Nea reaches him first, and cries. She has a hard time catching her breath.
肯尼斯没料到我们会来。监狱告诉他有访客，但没说是谁。所以他起初很吃惊，然后看到托尼娅，感到高兴，他试图安慰她。“我没事，”他一直说。他把手举到窗口，她把手举起来去碰他的手。他的脖子上挂着一个超大的十字架。
Kenneth is not expecting us. The prison told him he had visitors coming, but not who. So he's startled at first, and then seeing Ton'Nea, pleased, he tries to comfort her. "I'm OK," he keeps saying. He brings his hand up to the window, and she brings hers up to meet it. Around his neck hangs an oversize cross.
他们花了最初的几分钟叙旧，主动说出老朋友在长时间分开后会说的细节。她搬到了德克萨斯。他的父母复合了。她的女儿准备参加舞会。她介绍罗宾和我，解释说他们和她在一起是因为我们正在为广播节目讲述她的故事，但我们没带录音设备。他提到了其他上过电视的囚犯。“这是广播，”她重复道。
They spend the first few moments catching up, volunteering the kind of details that old friends would after a long separation. She's moved to Texas. His parents have gotten back together. Her daughter's getting ready for prom. She introduces Robyn and me, explaining that we are with her because we are telling her story for a radio show, but that we couldn't bring recording equipment. He mentions other inmates who have gotten on television. "This is radio," she repeats.
前半小时左右，肯尼斯很有魅力。他友好、随和、放松。然后托尼娅讲到了她来的原因。她告诉他，她无法摆脱这个想法，即她本来可以阻止他的罪行。“我承担这个负担很多年了，”她告诉他。“我还能做什么？你还需要什么？”
For the first half hour or so, Kenneth's charming. He's friendly and easygoing, relaxed. Then Ton'Nea gets to why she came. She tells him that she can't shake the idea that she could somehow have prevented his crimes. "I've carried this burden for years," she tells him. "What else could I have done? What else did you need?"
肯尼斯没有犹豫。他甚至似乎没有考虑他的回答。“哦，你什么也做不了，”他说。“没有人能帮我。我知道我想做什么，而且我会去做的。”他继续说。“我以前是个坏孩子，我想让你觉得我做得对，但我就是做不到。”我不禁注意到，在此期间，托尼娅一边点头，一边看起来并不信服。
Kenneth doesn't hesitate. He doesn't even seem to think about his answer. "Oh, there's nothing you could have done," he says. "No one could have helped me. I knew what I wanted to do, and I was going to do it." He goes on. "I was a bad kid, and I wanted to do right by you, but I just couldn't." I can't help but notice that during this, Ton'Nea both nods and looks unconvinced.
她问起在法庭上的那一天，当时她作证，这对她来说意义重大。他轻描淡写地略过了。他记得很高兴见到她，讨厌那些对他作证的人。
She asks about that day in court, when she testified, which was monumental for her. He breezes past it. He remembers being happy to see her, and hating the people testifying against him.
然后，也许因为这是唯一真正可以谈论的事情，一个关于杀戮的独白。肯尼斯说，在他被定罪后的几年里，他很阴暗，充满怨恨，甚至想自杀。日子一天天过去，等待死亡的日子，从不向任何人，甚至向他自己，承认他为了被判死刑做了什么。
And then, maybe because it was the only thing really to talk about, a monologue about killings. Kenneth says that for years after his conviction, he was dark and resentful, even suicidal. One day blurring with the next, waiting for a date to die, never admitting to anyone, even himself, what he had done to be on death row.
他说他开始改变，有一天在翻阅审判文件时。他看着他的受害者，那个被他杀死的女孩的照片，活着，美丽。然后他把照片和她的尸检照片并排放在一起想，是我做的。他停顿了一下，用手捂住脸，好像他在收集足够多的力量继续下去。但看着肯尼斯重温这一点就像看一场糟糕的戏。词句与他的动作不连贯。他表演哭泣，垂下眼睛，摇头，用手臂遮住脸。当他再抬起头时，我没看到任何眼泪。
He began to change, he says, one day while flipping through the trial documents. He looked at the photo of his victim, the girl he killed, alive and beautiful. Then he held it side-by-side with her autopsy photo and thought, I did that. He pauses and puts a hand over his face, as if he's collecting himself enough to continue. But watching Kenneth relive this is like watching a bad play. The words are disconnected from his gestures. He makes a show of weeping, lowering his eyes, shaking his head, and covering his face with his arms. When he looks up again, I don't see any tears.
和大学生在一起时，他最初想要钱。但一旦肯尼斯拿到钱，他就放了他们俩。然后他开车沿路开了一个街区，停下来，意识到他们看到了他的脸，可以认出他。他告诉我们，他着迷于杀人的想法。想知道那会是什么感觉，他回忆说，然后话音落下。他回去，让他们乞求活命，然后一次又一次地向他们开枪。
With the university students, he'd wanted money, initially. But once Kenneth had gotten his cash, he let the two go. Then he drove a block down the road and then stopped, realizing they'd seen his face, and could identify him. He tells us he was fascinated with the idea of killing someone. Wonder what it would be like, he recalls thinking, and trails off. He went back, let them beg for their lives, and shot them, over and over.
然后是越狱的受害者。一名农民，那个有卡车的人，在肯尼斯射杀他时正试图逃跑。最后是这个。在密苏里州的汽车追逐后，州警让肯尼斯走过去看送货司机毫无生气的尸体，以为肯尼斯会感到后悔。相反，肯尼斯说他看到的只是阻碍他逃跑的人，他朝尸体吐了口水。
Then the victims of his prison break. A farmer, the one with the truck, was trying to run away when Kenneth gunned him down. And finally, this. After the car chase in Missouri, state troopers made Kenneth walk over and look at the lifeless body of the delivery driver, thinking Kenneth would be remorseful. Instead, Kenneth says all he saw was the man who got in the way of his escape, and he spit on the body.
这看起来或听起来并不像在吹嘘。这是完全不同的事情。肯尼斯看着我们，看到托尼娅哭了，又低下头，这次不可信地上下移动他的肩膀。
This doesn't look or sound like bragging. It's something else altogether. Kenneth looks at us, sees Ton'Nea crying and looks down again, this time moving his shoulders up and down unconvincingly.
监狱里没有发生的事情是这样的。他没有告诉托尼娅他对给她造成的痛苦感到抱歉，或者对让她代替他站上证人席感到抱歉，尽管他知道他的清白是个骗局。他不问她的生活，或者这些年来她过得怎么样。他确实问了一件事。如果我们再来，我们会带相机吗？
Here's what doesn't happen at the prison. He doesn't tell Ton'Nea he's sorry for the pain he caused her, or for letting her take the stand on his behalf, knowing his innocence was a farce. He doesn't ask about her life, or how she's been doing all these years. He does ask one thing. If we come back again, are we bringing cameras?
4点半，我们回到了车里，大家都在试图理解刚才发生的事情。
At 4:30 we head back to the car, all of us trying to make sense of what just happened.
你曾经告诉我你经常想肯尼斯，就像刚才发生了什么，这一整集。你认为今天之后，你能够少想他一点吗？
You told me once that you think about Kenneth a lot, like just, what happened, this whole episode. Do you think after today, you'll be able to think about him less?
我想我将能够放下那些事情，那些我承担的负担，即你是否做了你本可以做的一切？是否有什么别的话你可以说。是否有什么别的事你可以做。我不知道。我想我可以把那件事搁置起来。那就是让我彻夜难眠的原因。因为我觉得还有更多我们可以做的事情。但他证实，除非上帝来到地球站在他面前，否则他会做他想做的事。他对此非常清楚。你阻止不了我，而且我爱你。我爱我的妈妈。她阻止不了我。我爱我的妹妹。她阻止不了我。这就是我要做的。
I think I will be able to let those things, those burdens that I carried, of did you do everything you could have done? Is there something else you could have said. Is there something else you could have done? I don't know. I think that I can lay that to rest. And that was what was keeping me up at night. Because I just felt like there was more we could have done. But he gave confirmation that short of God coming to Earth and standing in front of him, he was going to do what he wanted to do. He was very clear about that. You were not going to stop me, and I loved you. I loved my mama. She wasn't going to stop me. I love my sister. She wasn't going to stop me. This is what I was going to do.
她说她希望他感到后悔，并且在上帝面前变得正直，但她就是说不准。当他说他多年来一直否认杀过人时，她不相信。她谈论的越多，她发现越多可以反驳的东西，包括最大的一件事，即她本来可以做些什么。
She says she hopes he's remorseful, and has gotten right with God, but she just can't tell. She doesn't buy it, when he said he was in denial himself for years, about having killed anyone. The more she talks, the more she finds things to discredit, including the biggest thing, that there was nothing she could have done.
她说她希望他能感到悔悟，并且已经向上帝忏悔，但她实在看不出来。当他说自己多年来一直否认曾杀过人时，她根本不相信。她说得越多，就越发现有东西可以推翻，包括最重要的一点，那就是她本可以做些什么来改变这一切。
You know, he said that, but let's go back to his start. He said that we couldn't do anything to help him. But when, in actuality, as a nine and ten year old, you can provide Little League. You can provide activities. Now, this is the start of it.
你知道，他是那么说的，但让我们回到他的起点。他说我们对他无能为力。但实际上，作为一个九十岁的孩子，你可以提供小联盟的机会。你可以提供各种活动。这，就是一切的开始。
I wasn't with her on this one. From what I saw, all the Little League in the world was not going to stop Kenneth.
在这件事上我并不支持她。据我所见，全世界的小联盟比赛也无法阻止肯尼斯。
It's still hard to say it. I don't think you'll ever get me to say--
现在说出来还是很难。我想你永远也别想让我说出——
Never get you to say what?
你知道，他是那么说，但让我们回到他的起点。他说我们不能帮他任何忙。但实际上，作为一个九岁和十岁的孩子，你可以提供小联盟运动。你可以提供活动。现在，这是开始。
That we did everything we could. Because I still, even with him where he is, I'm still going to search for what I could have done.
我不同意她这一点。从我看到的情况来看，世界上所有的小联盟都阻止不了肯尼斯。
Two weeks later, I visit Ton'Nea and her husband, Shawn, at their house. I'm curious how the trip to visit Kenneth has affected the rest of Ton'Nea's family. Shawn tells me Ton'Nea's been keeping the kids on an even shorter leash than usual.
很难说出口。我想你永远不会让我说——
With her visiting Kenneth, talking to Kenneth, I knew probably for the next six months, around here at the house, everything going to be a boot camp, with the kids.
永远不会让你说出什么？
So you knew she was going to come back more-- no matter what happened-- that she was going to come back from this more determined.
我们做了所有我们能做的事情。因为我仍然，即使他在那里，我仍然会寻找我本来可以做的事情。
Oh, I know my wife. I kind of felt for the kids. I really know she was going to-- In a good way. In a good way. I find myself defending them a little more, probably, than what I should.
两周后，我拜访了托尼娅和她的丈夫肖恩。我好奇去监狱探访肯尼斯如何影响了托尼娅的其他家人。肖恩告诉我，托尼娅对孩子们一直保持着比平时更紧的管束。
Shawn said that even before we went to Arkansas, he knew that his wife would never come home and accept the idea that there was nothing to be done for Kenneth.
因为她去看望肯尼斯，和肯尼斯交谈，我大概知道在接下来的六个月里，家里的一切都会像新兵训练营一样，对孩子们来说。
Sometimes she'd put blinders on. And I don't think she always look at the possibility of the other side. And in Kenneth's situation, there was a possibility that he did do it. She'll get something that she believe in, she will put her all and all into it. For me, she get too passionate sometimes. She's pretty headstrong. And I don't know if that's a good or bad thing.
所以你知道她会变得更——无论发生了什么——她会从这件事中回来变得更加坚定。
Ton'Nea told me later that she had never heard him say that before, and sitting next to him that day, she couldn't let this go by.
哦，我了解我的妻子。我确实为孩子们感到难过。我真的知道她会——以一种好的方式。以一种好的方式。我发现自己比我应该做的更多地为他们辩护，可能。
You know that I've spent my life being passionate. And I have a true, true respect for people that need to be connected with. I think a lot of it has to do with, if somebody hadn't seen the good in me, I don't know where I would be right now. And if sometime there's someone that I'm wrong about, I'll accept that. But it'll never change, me wanting to help people, because I've been helped my whole life by people blessing me, believing in me when I didn't believe in myself. So I know the power of that. And I don't think I'm ever going to give up trying.
肖恩说，甚至在我们去阿肯色州之前，他就知道他的妻子永远不会回家并接受肯尼斯没有办法救了的想法。
Especially now, with a house full of children, the youngest going into first grade.
有时她会戴上眼罩。而且我不认为她总是看到这一面的可能性。而在肯尼斯的处境中，有一种可能性是他确实做了。她会得到她相信的东西，她会把她所有的精力都投入其中。对我来说，她有时太有激情了。她很固执。我不知道这是好是坏。
I think, coming back, there was a lot of anxiety that I was still working through after the visit. And being sluggish at work, and it's like, OK, what's going on? I'm waking up at 3 o'clock, I'm waking up at 4 o'clock. I was having moments of just waking up and restlessness.
托尼娅后来告诉我，她从未听过他说这些，那天坐在他旁边，她无法让这件事过去。
I sleep light. And I'm always up in the middle of the night, watching TV, and she was-- I found her taking the remote from me at 3:00 in the morning. I mean, she usually, when she goes to sleep, she'll sleep through the night. But for about a week, there were several times that she was waking up during the night.
你知道我一生都是充满激情的。而且我对于需要被联系的人有着真正、真正的尊重。我想这与如果有人没有看到我身上的好，我不知道我现在会在哪里有很大关系。而且如果有时有人我弄错了，我会接受这一点。但这永远不会改变，我想帮助人们，因为我一生都受到人们祝福我、在我不相信自己的时候相信我。所以我知道这力量。而且我不认为我会放弃尝试。
I was waking up, because it was a nightmare. And I'm in prison, sitting across from one of my children. And I just-- the anxiety came from just thinking about my family, and how can I prevent this from happening? And making sure that I don't ever have to look through a glass and talk to them from a prison cell.
特别是现在，家里满是孩子，最小的孩子要上一年级。
Lately, Ton'Nea is worried about one of her kids in particular. A few months ago, when the whole family was having dinner at a neighbor's house, one of her nephews, now her son, stole a wallet from the neighbor's purse. Ton'Nea and Shawn found it, and made him take the wallet back and apologize. But it's not lost on her that this nephew is about the same age as Kenneth was when she first met him all those years ago, when he was arrested for stealing. Ton'Nea had wanted to come home from Arkansas and leave Kenneth behind. Instead he's still here, in a way he hasn't been before.
我想，回来后，探访后我仍然在努力解决很多焦虑。而且工作时迟钝，就像，好的，发生了什么？我在3点钟醒来，我在4点钟醒来。我正经历着只是醒来和不安的时刻。
Laura Beil lives in Cedar Hill, Texas.
我睡得轻。而且我总是在半夜起来，看电视，而她当时——我发现她在凌晨3点从我手里拿走遥控器。我的意思是，她通常，当她睡觉时，她会整晚睡觉。但大约一周，有好几次她在夜里醒来。
[MUSIC-- BAD INTENTIONS BY SHONA FOSTER]
我醒来，因为这是一个噩梦。我身处监狱，坐在我的一个孩子对面。我只是——焦虑来自思考我的家人，我如何才能防止这种情况发生？并确保我永远不必透过玻璃在牢房里与他们交谈。
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Eric Mennel, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from [? Mickey Meek ?]. Music help from [? Damien Grafe, ?] Seth Linde is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Special thanks to Jesse Hardman. The Spanish interpreter for the opening story in today's show was Juan Carlos Correo from the Cross-Cultural Interpreting Services of the Heartland Alliance.
最近，托尼娅特别担心她的一个孩子。几个月前，全家人在邻居家吃饭时，她的一个侄子，现在是她的儿子，从邻居的钱包里偷了一个钱包。托尼娅和肖恩发现了它，让他把钱包拿回去并道歉。但她没忘的是这个侄子和肯尼斯当年她第一次遇见他、因偷窃被捕时大约一样大。托尼娅本来想从阿肯色州回家，把肯尼斯留在后面。但他却依然在这里，以一种之前没有的方式。
Today's show is our last show with Eric Mennel as our intern. He did all of the mixes for Act One of today's show, which was par for the course for him. He's been mixing stories for us for months, and has been super capable at everything else we have thrown at him. He's on the job market. If you are looking to hire somebody like that, drop us a line. Thank me later, Eric.
劳拉·贝尔住在德克萨斯的锡达希尔。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, God knows, he's always loved table scraps, which perhaps explains his lifelong dream.
[音乐-- 肖娜·福斯特的《Bad Intentions》]
--to get on a slop truck, and slip into a bucket of slop. It just is like hog slop.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、埃里克·门内尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自米奇·米克。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉菲，塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。特别感谢杰西·哈德曼。今天节目开篇故事的西班牙语口译员是来自心脏联盟跨文化口译服务的胡安·卡洛斯·科雷奥。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
今天的节目是我们实习生埃里克·门内尔的最后一个节目。他完成了今天节目第一幕的所有混音工作，这对他来说是例行公事。几个月来他一直为我们混音故事，并且对我们丢给他的其他一切工作都非常有能力。他正在找工作。如果你正在寻找雇佣这样的人，给我们写信吧。埃里克，以后再谢谢我。
PRI. Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，上帝知道，他一直喜欢吃剩饭剩菜，这也许解释了他一生的梦想。